LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live at I/O
from Moscone here at
Google I/O 2013.
I'm Louis Gray from the Google
Developers Live, and my guest
right now is Nicolas Garnier.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Hi, Louis.
LOUIS GRAY: On the Drive team.
He comes to us from Zurich,
Switzerland.
So that's quite the trip.
We definitely appreciate
your coming by.
And today we're here to
talk about the first
year of Google Drive.
It's hard to imagine it's
only been one year.
But it came out last year.
Last time we were here, we were
talking about docs, and
spreadsheets, and each piece
in its own little slot.
So maybe you can give us a
little understanding of what's
happened in the last
12 months.
How has Drive evolved?
NICOLAS GARNIER: Well, 12 months
ago, basically, we
launched Google Drive, right?
And people were really
anticipating this launch.
It's really what people
expected, right?
It's really a service for people
to back up all of the
files that they have on their
desktop and open them online.
And basically allowed them to
share these files with their
friends, for example,
or their colleagues.
But really, lots of the effort
that we have put in, and lots
of, I would say, the
groundbreaking features that
we've been working on are really
related to the SDK of
Google Drive.
So the SDK, that's basically the
API and a bunch of other
features that I'm going
to tell you
about in this session.
LOUIS GRAY: And that really sets
it up for developers who
want to develop against
the Drive API.
NICOLAS GARNIER: It's really
for apps to really build on
top of Google Drive and really
use Google Drive as basically
the file system for the
web platform, right?
You can find nowadays really
cool, really powerful apps
online, for example, photo
editors, I don't know, even
faxing applications or
diagram editors.
All of that.
So even Google Docs, right, all
of these apps that went
online that are great editors.
We hope for them to actually use
Google Drive, really, as
the central place to read files
and basically save files
to so that users have this
central place to really hold,
and manage, and organize
all of their files.
Not only the files that they
have on the desktop, but
really use that for really the
web platform, as I said.
All of the apps that are out
there that need to save files,
that need to read files,
basically.
LOUIS GRAY: And you talked
about, you look at a
differentiation between backup,
which is essentially a
passive environment where you
just send files from one place
and put them in another to
retrieve later, to more of an
active, interactive piece with
applications touching those
files, sharing with
other people.
One thing that I've enjoyed is
you essentially have, whether
it be Chrome OS or any other
application, if you log into
your account on Google, your
Drive documents are
everywhere, wherever you fall.
And it makes it really feel like
any computer in the world
is my computer.
It's no longer that
my files are on my
desktop living somewhere.
Do you feel like that's
really changed the way
users perceive it?
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
I think that's really one of the
big reasons why people are
really moving away from the
desktop and doing more and
more things online, basically,
alongside with all of the cool
apps that are available.
But to actually make these web
apps better and make them
actually want to use Google
Drive as an SDK, we've been
launching a bunch of features
[INAUDIBLE] this year.
I can just mention a few
ones really quickly.
There's now a way for people who
have files on Google Drive
to publish their files as
a website, basically.
That's one of the real
interesting features.
We launched a real time API
allowing apps to build
real-time collaboration feature,
web apps that are
using Google Drive.
Real-time collaboration feature
that would be similar
to Google Docs, for instance.
We've seen some really,
really cool apps that
are using that future.
What else?
LOUIS GRAY: One of the good
things about being at Google
Developers Live and getting to
see the Google Drive team
present is I've seen a lot of
these real-time interactive
features with the
Realtime API.
I've seen a number of the
developers out there who have
tapped into it for
the first time.
And we've been able to see a lot
of the tips, be it Claudio
or Stephen and the members of
your team talking about how to
drive your first Drive apps,
be it in Java or C++, or
JavaScript.
It really seems like the Drive
APIs are exceptionally
flexible for any type of code
that comes in there.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah,
definitely.
Actually, most of our APIs at
Google have this really wide
set of client libraries.
We're really trying to make
it easy for everyone to
integrate with us.
I think we have client
libraries in
eight or nine languages.
You know, iOS, Java, Python,
PHP, et cetera, JavaScript.
And for JavaScript developers,
and for web apps in general,
we are really trying to
make it even easier.
We launched, for example,
a bunch of
widgets, widgets that--
basically really common UI
components, features of Drive
that we don't want developers
out there to have to rebuild
everything again.
So we provide a bunch
of widgets to them.
Like for example the picker,
which is this little file
explorer they can embed
in their website.
So they don't have to
build that, right?
They can just trigger
that widget.
It's just a few lines
of JavaScript.
And people can go ahead and
select a file in their drive.
It's like this little
UI popping up.
It's pretty nice.
We have the same for sharing
a file, right?
So we'll allow developers to
actually embed that sharing
widget, the same one we use
in Google Docs, or Google
Spreadsheet, or Google Drive, to
embed that UI directly into
their website.
So they don't have to rebuild
that feature again.
LOUIS GRAY: In what fashion
would somebody use Google
Drive as the back end
for their website?
I've seen the feature launched,
and it's really
interesting to understand,
what kind of actual
deployments have you
seen so far?
NICOLAS GARNIER: So I think the
best suited apps for this
currently are productivity
apps.
That's really the type
of application.
Online productivity apps.
That's really the type of
application that can really
use the most of our features
that are out there.
For example, I forgot to mention
that we have this
really, really great feature
that was available at the
launch of the API a year ago.
It's the ability for application
to integrate
directly with the user interface
of Google Drive.
So application can basically
register--
just like they would on your
local desktop computer, they
register to open certain
[INAUDIBLE] types.
They tell us, hey,
I can open image.
I'm an image editor, so I
support opening JPG and PNG
images, and stuff like that.
So when people actually
installed that web apps, or
connected, we call that, that
web apps to Drive, then from
within Drive they can, for
example, right-click on an
image or directly open an image
with that image editor.
For example, I can
cite a few ones,
Pixeler, Editor, or PicMonkey.
Those are the few cool image
editors that you can find
online that have a very, very
deep integration with the
Google Drive SDK,
basically, the
Google Driver user interface.
LOUIS GRAY: You mentioned
Pixeler.
They were actually one of the
first developer partners that
I asked Ali to take a look at.
As somebody who uses Chrome OS
every day, I want to have the
ability to get into image
editing, get really deep into
it, do the cropping and all
those things that you would do
typically with a native
desktop application.
It's been great to see the
integration with Drive there,
where you can take content that
is stored in Drive and
pass it right through
a system like that.
Now, we have only a
couple minutes.
I definitely wanted to say thank
you very much for coming
through, and talking with us
about Drive, and giving us an
update on the 12 months of
advancements that have happened.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Thanks
for hosting me.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
I appreciate you coming on GDL
at I/O. For those of you on
the live stream, we're going
to cut over to the sessions
momentarily.
And when we come back to GDL at
I/O I'll be joined with the
team working on games,
which were all
announced this morning.
Should have incredible
demos coming up.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Thank you.